OFFICE, HE IS A GOOD MAN.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
TUCKER UP NEXT.IN COLLEGE WAS I
OFFICE, HE IS A GOOD MAN.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
TUCKER UP NEXT.
♫♫
NOTE.
♫ >> Monica: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IF YOU’VE BEEN PAYING I TENSION
LATELY, YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOESN’T LIKE THE
MEDIA.
THE MEDIA FERVENTLY DON’T LIKE
HIM BACK.
IT IS A HATE-HATE RELATIONSHIP
THAT SEEMS TO BE GETTING MORE
CONTENTIOUS.
CNN THIS MORNING, THE PRESIDENT
GOT A STRIKINGLY POSITIVE HEALTH
EVALUATION YESTERDAY.
HERE WAS CNN’S TAKE ON IT.
OVERWEIGHT AND DOESN’T EXERCISE.
IN OTHER WORDS DOCTORS SAY HE’S
FINE, CNN CALLS HIM FAT.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE THE
BEGINNINGS.
EXCEPT FOR THE DAY THAT HE
LOBBED CRUISE MISSILES INTO
SYRIA WHICH DELIGHTED OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON AS IT ALWAYS DOES,
VIRTUALLY ALL OF TRUMP’S PRESS
COVERAGE HAS BEEN NEGATIVE.
REPORTERS DON’T SIMPLY DISAGREE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
POLICY, THOUGH THEY DO.
THEY FEEL PERSONAL CONTEMPT AND
LOATHING FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
THEIR BOSSES HAVE ENCOURAGED
THEM TO EXPRESS IT.
IN RETURN, THE PRESIDENT HAS
STRUCK BACK, DISMISSING THE
MEDIA AS FAKE NEWS.
MANY CASES HE’S BEEN RIGHT
OTHERS HE JUST ATTACKS NEWS HE
DOESN’T LIKE LIKE ALL
POLITICIANS.
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES, PART
OF THE REMEDY IS A RESPONSIBLE
MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT, REPORTERS
WOULD RAISE THEIR STANDARDS AND
RUN FEWER FALSE STORIES.
THESE ARE NOT NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SUDDENLY THERE’S A MASSIVE AND
EAGER AUDIENCE FOR CONSPIRACY
THEY ARIES, EXACT LIG WHY
THEY’RE GOING 24/7 WITH THIS
RUSSIA NONSENSE ON SOME OF THE
OTHER NETWORKS.
IT IS VERY LUCRATIVE FOR THEM.
THERE’S ANOTHER REASON, TOO.
IN THE AMERICA OF 2018,
VICTIMHOOD IS POWER.
INSTEAD OF IMPROVING THEIR
JOURNALISM, IKTS OH EASIER FOR
REPORTERS TO COMPLAIN ABOUT HOW
THEIR VOICES ARE SOMEHOW BEING
SUPPRESSED.
THE IRONY, OF COURSE, FREE
EXPRESSION REALLY IS UNDER
ATTACK IN THIS COUNTRY AT THE
MOMENT.
MOST JOURNALISTS DON’T CARE OR
NOTICE IT.
VIEWS ARE SHOT OFF, TWITTER
ROUTINELY BANS ACCOUNTS FOR
SHOWING VIEWPOINTS THEY OPPOSE,
GOOGLE TAM PERCENT WITH SEARCH
RESULTS AND FIRES EMPLOYEES WHO
EXPRESS THOSE IDEAS.
YET WEIRDLY THE MEDIA APPLAUD
ALL OF THIS.
THEY’RE NOT DEFENDERS OF FREE
EXPRESSION, THEY ARE GUARDIANS
OF ORTHODOXY, ELITE ORTHODOXY.
TODAY, REPUBLICAN SENATOR JEFF
FLAKE OF ARIZONA TOOK THEIR
SIDE.
IN A SPEECH ON THE SENATE FLOOR,
FLAKE COMPARED TRUMP’S CRITICISM
TO THE SOVIET DICTATOR JOSEPH
STALL LEARN, ONE OF HISTRY’S
MOST PROLIFIC MASS MURDERERS.
BARKING AT JIM ACOSTA DURING A
PRESS CONFERENCE IS LIKE
BUILDING DEATH CAMPS OR STAGING
A FAMINE IN UKRAINE.
NO ONE ACCUSED JEFF FLAKE OF
BEING A GENIUS.
HE IS RIGHT ON ONE POINT,
GOVERNMENT OFTEN IS THE OPPONENT
OF FREE EXPRESSION.
REMEMBER FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA KICKED NEWSPAPER
REPORTERS OFF THE CAMPAIGN
PLAIN, THEIR COVERAGE WASN’T
FAVORABLE ENOUGH.
YOU DON’T TLAEB?
IT HAPPENED.
THEN THERE WAS THE TIME THE OWE
BAM ADMINISTRATION THREATENED TO
BAN FOX FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS CORPS WE DIDN’T SUCK UP
HARD ENOUGH.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SUBPOENAED THE PHONE RECORDS
FROM THE ASSOCIATED PRESS OR
NAMED FOX NEWS REPORTER JAMES
ROSEN IN A CRIMINAL COMPLAINT.
.
OBAMA DESCRIBED THIS NEWS
ORGANIZATION, FOX, AS, QUOTE,
DESTRUCTIVE FOR THE LONG TERM
GROWTH OF A COUNTRY THAT HAS A
VIBRANT MIDDLE CLASS.
FOX NEWS CAUSES POVERTY.
THESE ATTACKS ON PRESS FREEDOM
WON’T FOR YEARS.
WHERE WAS JEFF FLAKE THEN?
WE DON’T REMEMBER HIM COMPARING
PRESIDENT OBAMA TO JOSEPH STALIN
OR BOTHERING TO DEFEND US.
JEFF FLAKE DIDN’T HATE OBAMA THE
WAY HE HATES DONALD TRUMP, OBAMA
DIDN’T THREATEN THE COMFORTABLE
THING FLAKE HAD CARVED OUT FOR
HIMSELF.
GRAHAM OR A DOZEN OTHER
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO SECRETLY
DESPISE THEIR OWN VOTERS, OAT
POOM A YEARS WERE A PERFECT TIME
FOR YOU.
YOU COULD COMPLAIN ABOUT
DEMOCRATIC CONTROL OF
GOVERNMENT, GIVE A KNEW FLOOR
SPEECHES, TV HITS, THEN GO HOME.
YOU DIDN’T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING
OR CHANGE ANYTHING.
WITH THE POLITICAL EQUIVALENT OF
A NO-SHOW JOB IT WAS NICE WORK
IF YOU COULD GET IT.
THERE’S A REASON REPUBLICANS
HAVEN’T DELIVERED A SINGLE MAJOR
CONSERVATIVE LAW SINCE WELFARE
REFORM.
NO WONDER GUYS LIKE JEFF FLAKE
LOATHE TRUMP.
HE CALLED THEIR BLUFF.
SUDDENLY REPUBLICANS HAVE ALL OF
THE POWER FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
DECADES, THAT COULD ACTUALLY DO
WHAT VOTERS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
ASKED THEM TO DO FOR YEARS.
SECURE THE BORDERS.
THIS TIME FOR REAL.
SLOW THE FLOOD OF IMMIGRATION
THAT IS MAKING AMERICA POORER,
MORE CROWDED, AND DANGEROUSRY
UNSTABLE.
THEY DON’T WANT TO DO IT, THEIR
DONORS DON’T WANT THEM ON DO IT.
THEY CAN’T ADMIT IT SO THEY CALL
TRUMP STALIN.
IT ALL MAKES SENSE.
DAVIDSON IS A SENIOR
CORRESPONDENT FROM THE
FEDERALIST, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: TRUMP HATES
REPORTERS, I SEE WHY THEY DON’T
LIKE THAT, I DON’T ALWAYS LIKE
THE CRITICISM OF THE PRESS.
THEY STRIKE ME AS LESS DANGEROUS
AS AN ACTUAL STALINIST DYNAMIC
WHERE THE PRESS SUCKS UP TO
PEOPLE IN POWER.
I’M STRUCK HOW COMMON THAT WAS
FOR THE EIGHT YEARS PRECEDING
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND NO ONE
STEAD ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WHY?
>> WELL, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
REPORTERS FROM MAINSTREAM
JOUMENT LETS ROUTINELY TAKE
PRIVATE MEETINGS WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA, BE FED STORIES AND
NARRATIVES AS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION LIKES TO SAY,
THEN COME BACK AND REGURGITATE
THEM POINT BAY POINT IN SUPPORT
OF OBABA ADMINISTRATION POLICY
THAT WAS BEING SOLD THAT DAY.
THIS WAS THE STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE FOR MAJOR NEWS OUTLETS
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
AND NOW, THEY HAVE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHICH OFFENDS
THEM AND THEIR SENSIBILITIES,
AND THEY’RE OFFENDED BY THE
POLICIES THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
PUSH.
SO THEY ENGAGE IN THE SORT OF
HYSTERICAL OVERBLOWN CRITICISM
THAT WE SAW JEFF FLAKE JOIN IN
ON TODAY ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
>> Tucker: JEFF FLAKE IS
MEDIOCRITY, AND RETIRING.
I’M INTERESTED IN THE REPORTERS
THAT SHAPE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IS GOING IN THE WORLD.
IT SEEMS WEIRD THEY’RE IGNORING
THE ACTUAL CRISIS IN FREE
EXPRESSION, WHICH IS REAL.
I’VE BEEN IN THE WORKFORCE 26
YEARS, NEVER A TIME IN MY
LIFETIME WHERE MORE PEOPLE WERE
FIRED MORE QUICKLY FOR
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINIONS IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC I DON’T SEE
COVERAGE OF THAT, WHY?
>> WELL, LIKE YOU SAID BEFORE,
THE OPPRESSED CHOOSE -- PRESS
CHOOSES NOT TO SEE THAT.
ALL OF THE PEOPLE GETTING FIRED
HAVE THE WRONG VIEWS.
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK BACK TO THE
FIRING OF BRENDAN IKE AT MOW SIL
A AS A CANARY IN THE COAL MINE,
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME AGO,
BUT THAT WAS A HARBINGER MUCH
THINGS ON COME, THAT ARE
WIDESPREAD WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE FACEBOOK AND TWITTER THAT
ARE MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS NOW THAT
FUNCTION LIKE MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT HAVE THESE DRACONIAN
POLICIES WHERE THEY’RE OBVIOUSLY
CENSORING VIEW THESE DON’T LIKE.
THEY’RE OBVIOUSLY DON’T REALLY
CARE ABOUT FREE EXPRESSION.
YOU SAW THE UNDERCOVER VIDEOS OF
TWITTER, SAYING WE COOPERATE
WITH THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IN
BANNING PEEP FROM TWITTER ALL
THE TIME.
THEY’RE NOT REALLY INTERESTED IN
FREE EXPRESSION.
AND IT’S TROUBLING TO SEE JUST
HOW DISINTERESTED THEY ARE,
UNINTERESTED IN THE ISSUE AT
ALL.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY’RE THE
GUARDSIANS, THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THEY OUGHT TO BE, THEY’RE THE
GUARDIANS OF ORTHODOXIC RATHER
THAN PROTECTORS, THE JOURNALIST
SHOULD TAKE THE PLACE OF THE GUY
WHO STOOD UP AND GOT ONE
OPINION.
PRETTY BENIGN E-MAIL ABOUT
DIVERSITY AND THE WHOLE STAFF OF
"BUSINESS INSIDER" SAID HE’S A
THREAT TO THE REPUBLIC.
WHAT ARE THOSE PEOPLE POSING AS
JOURNALISTS?
>> THE ONE THING JEFF FLAKE GETS
WRONG AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
GETS WRONG, THE NUMBER ONE
THREAT IF THERE’S A MAIN THREAT
TO OUR DEMOCRACY, WHEN IT COMES
TO THE MEDIA, IT’S THAT THE
MEDIA HAS TOTALLY THROWN AWAY
ITS CREDIBILITY WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE WAS THIS GALLOP POLL THAT
SHOWED MORE AMERICANS HAVE A
NEGLIGENCE IF I HAVE VIEW OF THE
MEDIA THAN HAVE A POSITIVE VIEW
OF THE MEDIA.
THAT ISN’T GOOD FOR A DEMOCRACY.
WE NEED TO HAVE A ROBUST,
CREDIBLE MEDIA TO HOLD POWER
ACCOUNTABLE, AND TO TO THE
CITIZENRY.
WE DON’T HAVE THAT.
THE MEDIA DOES NOT SEE ITSELF AS
THE GUARDIANS OF FREE SPEECH,
THE GUARDIANS OF COMMON
AMERICANS, HOLDING POWER
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY SEE THEMSELVES AS, AS YOU
SAY, PROTECTORS OF THE STATUS
QUO.
>> Tucker: IF THEY WERE HALF AS